بلا حدود هكذا تريد
لشراكته الشامله ان تكون
نم التعاون العسكري بين الجانبين بشكل
لافت في الشهور الاخيره
الصين تجري القوات البحريه الصينيه
والروسيه مناوراتها المشتركه الاحداث على
مدى اسبوع
البحري لكونه بات مركز ثقل الصراع العالمي
والقطب الجاذبه لتحالفاته لكن هل لتوقيت
المناورات من دلاله يسال مهتمون بالمساله
مهتمون غيرهم يستوقفهم نشاط سياسي متزامن
انتهى بنائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي في
بيت بعد لقائه لمتر مدفيدف اكد رئيس الصين
ان تطوير شراكه استراتيجيه مع روسيا خيار
استراتيجي طويل الاماد
لن تعدم مشككين غربيين هنا في ان تلك
الشراكه لا حدود لها حقا في روسيا هي
الساعه منذ بدء حربها على اوكرانيا لتمثيل
روابطها الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والامنيه مع
الصين
تفعل ذلك من مطلق الرؤيه الروسيه الصينيه
المشتركه الناشده نظاما عالميا عاجلا
متعدد الاقطاب ام هل تحاول موسكو تعويض
خسارتها العلاقات والاسواق الغربيه بعد
حربها على اوكرانيا
توصف بحرب الطاقه مع الغرب كما ان
العقوبات الدوليه وضعت اقتصاد بلاده تحت
باطن شديد
بقوه سيبيريا سيحل الخط بذلك محل خاطئ
انابيب نور ستريم اثنان الذي يضخ الغاز
الى اوروبا ويواجه عقوبات بعد اندلاع حرب
اوكرانيا
قد يشعر ذلك حلفاء كيف الغربيين بان
بيجينغ تحد من اثر عقوباتهم على موسكو
ومحاولتهم عزل لها دوليه ليس تماما
الصينيون ليس هو كمخاطره فهم لم يؤيد
صراحه للحرب على اوكرانيا بل يقر الروس
انفسهم بوجود اسئله
بشان تلك
الحربائها المتضاده رؤاهم بحذر شديد تجدها
تعمل على تمثيل الصلات مع الشريك الروسي
وتساعد في تجنيب اقتصاده لانهيار وتجدها
في الوقت عينه تولي اهميه اكبر لمصالحها
مع الغرب فذاك ما يضمن بقاء اقتصادها قويا
عبر التجاره والصادرات والاستثمارات